The Joe Rogan Experience he's doing all
that anti-aging [__] yeah who's that one
billionaire that I was telling you about
he like he takes blood transfusions from
his son that guy's weird man but he does
look younger he looks great but I mean
um you probably could look that there's
guys that look that good that are his
age that just work out all the time well
that's what I don't know because he's
doing so many things that I don't I
don't know what thing what is he going
overboard with like he takes like 40
vitamins in the morning and 40 more in
the afternoon he always he always sleeps
at the same exact time no matter what
that seems tedious I know it's like I'd
rather just die sooner you know like I
was telling you I had a headache last
night because you know all the [__]
that's going on the club nonsense
there's nothing bad but so uh then I had
a hard time going to sleep and then I
got up in the morning and I was foggy as
[__] got in the cold plunge like I know
I'm not at Optimum today yeah I know it
but you know that's life that's life
that is life suck it up [__]
like is that him and his son so he looks
to me like a normal fit 40 year old guy
nah show but show a picture of him from
like five years ago well do you look bad
he just did better he he looks worse
yeah he looks better now well maybe back
then he was working see that's him right
there see what the uh is he working
still
yeah go back
oh that's him right that's him right
there oh well also it looks like he lost
weight he got fitter yeah he went gone
which makes you healthier he looks like
more like a superhero than goth like
what is that strap on his shoulder
what's he doing is that a bulletproof
vest is that guy a superhero what is
that what is that outfit imagine wearing
that outfit if you showed up at the the
mothership with that outfit that would
be like Brian Simpson what the [__] are
you smoking Tony my rocket Toady would
rock that cowboy with a big belt buckle
no but but I bet you I bet you it's
probably something that like lets a
certain frequency of light to his
nipples that keeps him retain vitamin D
right right what is that stupid shirt
man that shirt's ridiculous yeah he's
got them zero shoes on
yeah yeah it's always doing all the face
stuff too see that's another thing that
they can do they do this face thing oh
Jesus what happened to his face I think
he's just got cold oh this is a
different guy and he said I tried yeah
but what is he doing right there it says
45 year old CEO to the right of that
yeah
so what's he doing okay so there's
yeah there's a thing that they do where
they like put these like micro needles
all over your face and then they rub
stem cells in your face I know a few
people that have had that but now
imagine the sun doing this from 18. you
know yeah that now that might be a whole
different thing yeah so he eats 2 000
calories a day but he's vegan yeah
that's not good
that's interesting but that's
interesting that he would choose that
route the the vegan route for longevity
because there's a lot of you know
nutritional pitfalls in that can you not
make up for those you can cause like he
said he takes like 50 yeah it's possible
it's possible to do but the most
nutrient dense foods are red meat that's
the most nutrient dense foods there's
just a lot of weird propaganda you might
switch it up
well who knows I mean he doesn't look
that good there though so that that
thing again
but it's like for a lot of people on
vegan diets it's hard to put Mass on
he looks okay
but he looks like a normal 45 year old
guy that's fit and I think that's his
dad too see that picture right there in
the middle
him his son and his dad all did the
transfusions I'm not sure I like that
picture
him in the middle but like why were you
looking at me like that imagine if you
go over someone's house and the Son and
the dad and the little kid they're all
posed like this like come on
what what are you doing so I went over
your house it's like a cowboy you were
there with uh you know two other dudes
which I would be like hey man I'm Gonna
Leave we were embracing yeah I mean I
want you guys to be happy right it's not
as bad as though no the one on the right
is normal I'm like Joe this is how he's
like hey this is how we stay younger Joe
we it's cuddle cuddle puddles it looks
like his dad's not listening
intergenerational cotopo that belt
buckle is [__] straining yeah well
he's definitely he's definitely holding
in his stomach yeah on top of that like
that guy's not listening isn't it funny
like the sun is on this crazy Health
kick that dad looks like he's eating
meatball subs oh yeah well I think he I
think he was estranged from the dad and
the son until like recently oh and they
got back together for the transfusion